Veamos, tenemos esta gráfica aquí, donde
"t" es la variable independiente en el eje horizontal
y "d" es la variable dependiente en el eje vertical.
Y aquí tenemos esta tabla, aparentemente
la tabla corresponde a la gráfica.
Cuando "t" es igual a 1, "d" es igual a 40,
cuando "t" igual a 2, "d" es igual a 80,
así es que estos valores corresponden a puntos sobre
la recta y luego nos explican.
Estás comprando una membresía en un gimnasio.
La membresía cuesta 40 dólares por mes.
En la gráfica y tabla de arriba, "d" es el
número total de dólares que pagas por tu membresía,
aquí tenemos "d", y "t"es el tiempo en meses,
que conservas la membresía.
Escribe una ecuación para la cantidad de
dinero, "d",
que pagas por tu membresía del gimnasio si conservas la membresía por "t" meses.
Y aquí lo vemos, el primer mes pagas 40 dólares,
el segundo mes pagas otros 40 dólares,
has pagado 80 dólares.
Puedes ver eso en la gráfica que tenemos
aquí, has estado 0 meses no pagas nada,
has estado un mes pagas 40 dólares, el siguiente
mes otros 40 dólares, para llegar a 80.
Escribamos la ecuación aquí.
La variante dependiente aquí,
es la cantidad de dólares que pagas.
Y eso va a depender del tiempo.
¿Y cómo va a depender eso del tiempo en meses?
Bueno, vas a pagar, 40 dólares mensuales
por el número de meses.
Esto lo podemos escribir como "40*t" o esto
también lo podemos poner directamente como "40t".
Y creo que está bien, pues si mi tiempo es
0,
de acuerdo con la tabla o de acuerdo
con la gráfica no pago nada.
Si hubiera un costo de inscripción, tendríamos
que agregar entonces ese costo de inscripción
al cual le tendríamos que sumar la tarifa mensual.
Pero en este caso parece que estamos bien,
el costo en dólares es igual a 40
por el tiempo en meses.
El tiempo es la variable independiente que determina
el valor de la variable dependiente,
el costo en dólares que tienes que pagar.